we're getting to a point in video games
with some long-running series up to the
eighth ninth or tenth iterations one of
these is Assassin's Creed which has not
one but two games coming out this week
three if you include assassin's creed
chronicles china which is coming within
the unity season pass franchises are an
obvious attraction for major publishers
as a reliable source of revenue big
names like Assassin's Creed and call of
duty have capitalized on this revenue
with regular annual releases but it's
not always easy to keep things new and
fresh sometimes franchises will tweak a
formula in a way that will hugely
disappoint like resident evil 6 but
sometimes they constantly change and
constantly shine through like Mario
Galaxy and Super Mario 3d World
obviously all of this is hugely
subjective but here are some things I
think work really well to keep a
franchise feeling fresh first off
location a change of scenery is a pretty
good and common way to get players to
return to your franchise with the
exception of the SCO trilogy Assassin's
Creed pretty much does this every year
the latest location has you leaving the
open seas of the Caribbean for
traversing revolutionary France games
like far cry and the elder scrolls
change up the regions and provinces you
can explore with each installment but
this also happens in games without open
worlds massive actor Knights of the Old
Republic put emphasis on visiting new
planets and galaxies with each new title
and in the case of competitive games
like worms Street Fighter and smash
brothers the location and theme of the
stages filled with all sorts of weird
and wonderful touches are ways a big
deal Bioshock took itself from under the
sea to up in the clouds uncharted took
itself from jungle to snow to desert and
Diablo went from Hell to
all too okay that example but a drastic
location change is a great way of
keeping a good game interesting without
sacrificing too many familiar core
mechanics some games decide to also not
just the location but also the time
period started shooting dudes or
stabbing them doesn't feel too samey
cake battlefield for example which often
changes up its historical period the
shooter series is featured installments
that take place in World War 2 all the
way to the distant future and everything
in between the stuff that makes the game
recognizably battlefield is still there
but the altered setting allows the
environment weapons vehicles and combat
mechanics to undergo interesting
transformations heading further down the
narrative rabbit hole is a great reason
to stick with a story-driven franchise
but there's also a lot to be said for
evolving mechanics Mass Effect is a
really good example of a game that
adapted a lot over the course of its
trilogy to keep up with its growing fan
base I personally preferred when it was
a bit more complex and more like a
traditional RPG with the dense skill
assignment feature in Mass Effect 1 but
others like the way bioware committed to
giving the action more focus in its
sequels since you know the combat is all
about shooting space guns some people
were even weird enough to fall in love
with the competitive multiplayer in 3
we've seen games like Mario Brothers
spearhead technological changes jumping
into 3d and introducing the analog stick
with super mario 64 implementing analog
triggers in a big way with the flood
water pump in super mario sunshine and
perspective puzzles in Super Mario 3d
World on the 3ds we've also seen stuff
like spec ops changeup it's realistic
military shooter roots to adopt a daring
new narrative focused direction with its
11th installment in 2012 spec ops the
line whether a franchise decides to
differentiate itself from the trends or
go with them it's interesting to see how
a series carves out its narrative and
mechanical footing over the course of
several games in the interests of
keeping things interesting and if all
else fails
your franchise is getting dangerously
stale there's always space oh yes
civilization mario galaxy that one call
of duty leveling ghosts everyone loved
lego batman three Angry Birds as always
space seems to be the answer that was a
joke sort of let me know down in the
comments which franchise do you think is
still killing it after all this time and
which franchise you reckon we should
probably kill off and forget about I
will see you next week